Nous avons appris trois grandes leçons sur les relations.
La première est que les connexions sociales sont très bonnes pour nous
et que la solitude tue.
Il s'avère que les personnes qui sont plus connectées socialement
à leur famille, leurs amis, leur communauté,
sont plus heureux,
sont physiquement en meilleure santé,
et vivent plus longtemps
que ceux qui sont moins bien connectés.
Et expérimenter la solitude apparaît être toxique.
Les gens qui sont plus isolés des autres
que ce qu'ils souhaiteraient
s'avèrent être moins heureux,
leur santé décline plus tôt en milieu de vie,
les capacités de leur cerveau déclinent plus vite,
et ils ont des vies plus courtes que les gens qui ne sont pas seuls.
Et le plus triste
est qu'à tout moment,
plus d'un Américain sur cinq déclare se sentir seul.
Et on sait que l'on peut se sentir seul dans une foule
et seul dans un couple,
donc la deuxième leçon que nous avons apprise
est que ce n'est pas seulement le nombre d'amis que vous avez,
ou que vous soyez ou non engagé dans une relation,
mais c'est la qualité de vos relations proches
qui comptent.
Il s'avère que vivre au milieu du conflit est très mauvais pour notre santé.
Les mariages conflictuels par exemple, sans beaucoup d'affection,
sont très mauvais pour notre santé, peut-être même plus que le divorce.
Et vivre au milieu de bonnes, chaleureuses relations
est protecteur.
Une fois que nous avions suivi nos hommes au-delà de leurs 80 ans,
nous avons voulu revenir sur leur cinquantaine
et voir si nous pouvions prédire
qui deviendrait un heureux et vigoureux octogénaire
et qui ne le deviendrait pas.
Et quand nous avons rassemblé
tout ce que nous savions sur eux
à l'âge de 50 ans,
ce n'était pas leur taux de cholestérol à cet âge
qui a prédit comment ils allaient vieillir.
C'était leur niveau de qualité de leurs relations.
Les gens qui étaient les plus satisfaits dans leurs relations à 50 ans
étaient ceux en meilleure santé à 80 ans.
Et les relations complices réussies semblent nous prévenir
de quelques-uns des aléas du vieillissement.
Nos couples d'hommes et de femmes les plus heureux
ont rapporté, vers 80 ans,
que les jours où la douleur physique était la plus forte,
leur humeur restait tout aussi heureuse.
Mais les gens qui étaient malheureux dans leurs relations,
les jours où ils signalaient le plus de douleur physique,
cela était aggravé par plus de douleur émotionnelle.
Et la troisième grande leçon que nous avons retenue,
à propos des relations et de notre santé,
est que les bonnes relations ne font pas que protéger nos corps,
elles protègent nos cerveaux.
Il s'avère qu'être dans une relation solidement fixée
avec une autre personne pendant vos 80 ans
est protecteur,
que les gens qui sont dans des relations
où ils sentent vraiment qu'ils peuvent compter sur l'autre personne si besoin,
la mémoire de ces gens reste aiguisée plus longtemps.
Et les gens dans des relations
où ils ne sentent pas pouvoir compter l'un sur l'autre,
ces gens sont ceux qui ont expérimenté des déclins précoces de la mémoire.
Et ces bonnes relations, elles n'ont pas à être lisses tout le temps.
Certains de nos couples octogénaires pouvaient se disputer
continuellement,
mais tant qu'ils savaient pouvoir compter l'un sur l'autre en cas de coup dur,
ces disputes n'avaient pas d'effets négatifs sur leurs mémoires.
Donc,
ce message,
que les relations profondes
sont bonnes pour notre santé et notre bien-être,
cette sagesse est vieille comme le monde.
Pourquoi est-ce si dur à comprendre et si facile à ignorer ?
Eh bien, nous sommes humains.
Ce qu'on aimerait, c'est une solution facile,
quelque chose qu'on peut obtenir
qui rendrait nos vies belles et les maintiendrait comme ça.
Les relations sont désordonnées et compliquées,
et le dur labeur de s'accrocher à la famille et aux amis,
ce n'est ni sexy ni glamour.
C'est aussi tout le long de la vie. Ça ne finit jamais.
Les gens de notre étude sur 75 ans
qui étaient les plus heureux dans la retraite
étaient ceux qui ont activement travaillé à remplacer les collègues de travail
par de nouveaux amis.
Comme la génération Y dans ce récent sondage,
beaucoup de nos hommes, quand ils étaient de jeunes adultes,
croyaient vraiment que la célébrité, la richesse et le travail
étaient ce qu'ils devaient poursuivre pour réussir leur vie.
Mais encore et encore, pendant ces 75 ans, notre étude a montré
que les gens qui s'en sont le mieux tirés
étaient les gens qui ont compté sur les relations
avec de la famille, des amis, des communautés.
Et vous ?
Disons que vous ayez 25, ou 40, ou 60 ans.
A quoi ça peut ressembler finalement de favoriser les relations solides ?
Eh bien, les possibilités sont pratiquement sans fin.
Ça peut être quelque chose d'aussi simple que
remplacer le temps d'écran par du temps avec les gens
ou raviver une vieille relation en faisant quelque chose de nouveau ensemble,
de longues promenades ou des soirées,
ou rappeler ce membre de votre famille
à qui vous n'avez pas parlé depuis des années,
parce que toutes ces querelles familiales trop communes
laissent une empreinte terrible
sur les personnes qui s'en veulent l'une à l'autre.
J'aimerais terminer
sur une citation de Mark Twain.
Il y a plus d'un siècle,
il prenait du recul sur sa vie,
et il a écrit ceci :
« On n'a pas le temps, si brève est la vie,
pour les chamailleries, les excuses,
l'animosité, les appels à rendre des comptes.
On n'a que le temps pour aimer
et pas un instant de plus, pour ainsi dire,
que pour ça. »
Une belle vie est construite avec de belles relations.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)